Google Cloud updates Google is a leader
in the 2023 Gartner magic quadrant for
container management because wherever
our customers build and run containers
we aim to deliver the most simple
comprehensive and reliable container
platform for all workloads learn more
and see the report on the blog developer
time is precious and that's why we're
excited to share that log analytics
charts and dashboards in Cloud logging
is now in public preview meaning now you
can create a chart for your log analy
query results and save that chart to a
cloud monitoring dashboard and dig into
the issues so check all that out on the
blog and we'll see you next week for
more